[Music]
it's a little out there I know would you
be down
yeah I got you I'm down yeah
is this the person so do I like walk up
to Uber hello stranger how you doing
stranger I'm also a random stranger okay
and good to meet you dude where are you
from I'm from Germany from Germany what
you look very uh fit and healthy yeah it
could be fitter ah no you're very
beautiful you're a beautiful man yeah
you're also very handsome thank you
you're looking you're looking really
good today I wanted to say oh okay I
think you are I love your accent it's
very nice
really I like your hat it's nice I like
the texture
so I just wanted to tell you that your
dreams are valid
okay
so it's great oh it's it's pretty hot in
here
[Music]